we introduced Android go addition last
year with the aim to bring the latest
Android improvements to more entry-level
phone buyers there are now more than 200
Android go devices available in over 120
countries these devices are not only
popular in emerging markets such as
India and Brazil and Mexico but in the
United States as well with more than 100
manufacturers planning to release
devices before the end of the year this
is truly a global opportunity for your
apps to reach a wider audience
fundamentally the Android Go edition
experience is based on three key pillars
storage delivering twice the out of box
data storage compared to similarly
configured non go edition Android
devices data management helping users
minimize their data consumption with
features such as choosing content
quality in YouTube go and security
offering the same security features as
Android 9 such as find my device and
malware protection with Google Play
protect let's take a closer look at how
you can optimize your apps for Android
go start by targeting the most recent
Android API at the time of publishing
this video
that's Android PI API 28 this enables
you to gain benefits such as improved
memory use while helping your apps run
more efficiently on devices with one
gigabyte of RAM or less there's a clear
correlation between lower app size and
higher install rates this is especially
important for Android go Edition users
as they have limited storage capacity
and may incur download data charges
therefore keep your app under 40
megabytes and your game under 65
megabytes
the simplest and most impactful thing
you can do to reduce your app size is to
start using an Android app bundle
developers using an app bundle have seen
size savings of up to 65% this works
because Google Play uses your Android
app bundle to build and serve apks that
are optimized for each device
configuration this results in a smaller
app download for end-users by removing
unused code and resources needed for
other devices additional optimizations
you can do to reduce your app size are
replace PNG or JPEG files with HEI F or
WebP e assets for vector graphics use
vector drawables replace raw audio
format resources such as WAV with mp3 or
AAC
sources remove duplicate libraries and
whenever possible focus on mobile
optimized libraries shrink and optimize
your unused code and resources with
tools such as ProGuard you can use the
apk analyzer in Android studio or from
the command line to help understand how
these optimizations impact your apk size
another thing to check is your apps
proportional set size or PSS now this is
your apps physical memory footprint that
accounts for both shared and unshared
pages used by your app you can easily
check this using adb shell dump system
info aim for PS s ram usage below 50
megabytes for apps and below 150
megabytes for games and of course make
sure your app functions without ANR's
and crashes by testing and
double-checking on Android go Edition
powered devices after making the
optimizations it's time to publish now
one question you might have is do I
deliver the same after all my users or
specifically target an optimized version
of the app to users of Android Go
Edition for most developers we recommend
publishing the same app to all devices
for those who are using Android and
those who are using Android go Edition
by optimizing your app to run well on
Android go Edition devices all your
users stand to gain from the performance
benefits another option is to publish to
separate apps your existing app and a
lite app that is focused on Android go
edition devices you can target certain
countries in the light app or you can
target all devices in all locales it's
up to you now distributing a second app
isn't a decision to be taken lightly
you'll need to support and maintain its
code separately and dedicate resources
to growing and engaging a second
audience alongside your existing app as
we mentioned at the start of the video
Android Go is a tremendous opportunity
for you to grow your app or game
business to learn more check out the
resources listed in the video
description including the building for
billions guidelines where you will find
more tips for using memory power and
network bandwidth more efficiently in
your apps thanks for watching
[Music]